I welcome to the Ann and Ashley Show.
I am Ann and I'm Ashley.
And today we're gonna be talking about some snack ideas,
but before we get into today's episode,
please like and subscribe to our series of shows here.
And if you're on YouTube,
you can press the little notification button,
so you're sure to not miss an episode.
So, snack options.
There are a lot of things that are out there,
but what do we look for in healthy snack options
and what are some ideas for people?
So these are some ideas we've put together,
what we personally will consume for snacks,
but some things on these labels in particular
are non-GMO gluten-free, super foods.
There's going to be labels that are pretty small,
so we can pronounce or we know what's in the label.
And then, look, and we also like a mix of crunchy
and salty and flavorful depending on the day.
Obviously, there's some chip options here.
Again, she mentioned organic and non-GMO.
So anytime you're eating a chip,
obviously it's made with grains,
and so grains are typically sprayed with the pesticides.
So organic and non-GMO options are best,
especially if you are eating corn or chips
that have some soy in it or made with soy oils.
Those are highly sprayed with pesticides,
so you want to make sure those are organic.
This is actually a grain-free chip.
So this is made with cassava flour.
So cassava is a root vegetable,
so these are actually grain-free.
So this is great for a lot of people who maybe have
a lot of immune issues.
Sometimes grains can trigger autoimmune responses.
So these are really awesome.
Obviously with maybe some black emolle,
that would be excellent or some salsa.
These are gluten-free.
These are from Aldi.
This is the Aldi-Live G-Free brand.
So gluten-free, again, it's a chip.
This has some brown rice flour,
and I don't think there is some corn in there,
but it's dairy-free, gluten-free, nut-free,
soy-free, and woody-free.
That's a great option.
And then these are, these are really good.
They're veggie crisps.
So rice peas, rice peas, and black beans,
and again, these are non-GMO project verified.
And simple and greedy as you know,
you can read everything on the label,
which is really important,
because you want to make sure you're not eating
just a bunch of different chemicals
that your body has to filter out and process.
So simple ingredients, and then you can get creative.
So that kind of stands for a crunchy salted craving.
This is crunchy as well, but it's sweet.
These are apple chips,
and literally the ingredient is apples.
Organic apples, nothing else.
And they're sweet and crunchy.
I like those.
You didn't really care for those.
I don't really like to ride through in jail.
I like my group.
Yes, but they are good.
And they kind of, you know, if you're craving something sweet.
So those are good options.
These super food veggie cakes are really easy option.
And they come in so many different types of flavors.
I think there's like seasonal ones,
like a cranberry orange one was just out.
And then there's a spinach and egg white.
The veggie one is like your serving of vegetables
and one cake bite.
And it's great for like appetizers or a breakfast.
You can mix it with maybe your eggs.
So that's a great way to consume it.
Or just on its own, that's good too.
There's these green-free granola bars,
which have almonds, pecans, maple syrup, honey, coconut,
pumpkin seeds, cinnamon, sea salt, and vanilla.
So they're really good.
And yeah, they are good.
These are both at Costco,
and then of course these nuts are also at Costco.
Clearly we've eaten these at all.
Yes.
Mechadania nuts and then cashews,
which the ingredients is literally just the nuts
and sea salt for these options.
So yeah, and these are not roasted.
Yeah.
So you can roast nuts yourself.
I know that I have a dehydrator,
so I will soak nuts and then put them in the dehydrator,
which makes them crunchy without using that oil
and roasting them.
Sometimes when you have fats,
and then you're putting them at a high heat,
it can kind of oxidize those fats
and they can become carcinogenic.
So I don't know, I dry roast.
It can be like roasting.
Yeah, it doesn't make some crunchy.
You can do that with your apples too
if you want to make your own.
Or you can just buy the big.
Yeah, sometimes it's easier to just buy the big.
Yeah, so all these are great for on the go,
putting in your office drawer, desk drawer
in your purse for a snack, kids on the run.
Yeah, in your lunch, if you need some,
it's just naiming throughout the day.
Yeah, in the car.
Sometimes I leave snacks in my car,
so I'm that tempted to drive through or stop,
so I'm wearing grab something,
I'll have snacks in my car.
Yeah, but just a lot of options that are super tasty.
Most of these you're gonna find at Costco,
Costco's got great options for organic
and non-GMO snacking.
All they do is to get the live G-free brand,
but they have another brand,
which is their brand's simply nature, I believe it is,
which is organic, and most of the time,
you can find gluten free options as well,
but all they have is a lot of good options.
And I think the rest of this is from Costco as well.
I know Target has these in a small version
of super sized, yeah, but there's muffins too.
So these are kind of super food veggie cakes.
There's egg options, and then there's also muffin options,
so there's a chocolate zucchini.
Yeah, there's a zucchini in there,
so there's a chocolate chip banana,
and zucchini muffins, the orange cranberry muffins,
which are seasonal.
Yes.
And so just create a problem in the microwave
from literally, or a toaster oven.
Or a toaster oven?
Yeah, that's what we use to work.
Yes.
We'll be of excess.
Yeah.
But otherwise, I know, 35 seconds in the microwave,
and literally, you have just a nice scent.
So, yes.
So great.
Just some options.
We'll give any other nutritional questions,
feel free to contact my busier at the clinic
regarding nutrition, genetics,
or just if you want to say hi to us.
And just to help you guys,
something I know I can be overwhelming with food choices
and looking at nutrition labels,
and we're going to go and want to eat,
especially if you're one of our patients here
where we've put you on more in a restricted diet.
A lot of times people love questions.
Well, I don't know.
Is this on my list?
So, let us know if you're struggling,
and we can help you.
Thank you for watching.
Have a good day.